en el último vídeo hablábamos de cómo
definir una función cuya gráfica sea un
plano y principalmente que pasará por un
punto ya dado verdad y su orientación
también pudiera digamos especificarse en
términos de algunas derivadas parciales
vamos a repasar la conclusión del vídeo
anterior pero ahora vamos a hacerlo en
términos más abstractos muy bien
entonces nosotros queríamos una función
l que dependiera de dos variables x g y
como necesitábamos un punto por donde
pasar a este plano pues necesitamos el
punto x 0 10/0 z 0 este digamos un punto
dado en el espacio verdad entonces la
ecuación de este plano era una constante
que después podríamos determinar la
verdad que multiplica a x menos x 0
x 0 y luego sumamos b que multiplica
menos el punto o bueno la coordenada de
0 de nuestro punto dado verdad y
finalmente sumamos z 0 se está a cero y
este último digamos lo sumamos porque es
lo que queremos que nos digamos que es
el valor que queremos que tenga esta
función l
al evaluar en x 0 y 0 verdad y eso nos
da justamente z 0
ahora bien en las constantes a y b en
realidad están determinadas por las
derivadas parciales de nuestra función l
verdad en este caso pensamos que la
derivada parcial de l respecto de x es
ay es constante y la derivada parcial de
l con respecto de ye también es
constante y es b verdad y como dijimos
al ponerse está 0 al final estamos
garantizando que la gráfica de esta
función l que es el plano exactamente
pasa por el punto x 00 cet a 0 muy bien
dicho esto veamos cómo hallar el plano
tangente a la gráfica entonces este
punto se determina
exactamente con dos números nada más
necesitamos la coordenada x que es
aproximadamente 1 así que vamos a
ponerlo aquí 1 y también tenemos la
coordenada jay que más o menos de aquí
se ve que es menos 2 entonces tendremos
menos 2
ahora bien el tercer la tercera
coordenada se calcula evaluando la
función en este punto verdad evaluando
en este punto es decir es la altura que
vamos a tener sobre esta gráfica verdad
y quizás sea bueno poner aquí
exactamente qué funciona estamos
considerando para este ejemplo tenemos
la función fx igual a 3 menos un tercio
de x cuadrada menos de cuadrada esta es
la función que estamos considerando para
este vídeo muy bien entonces si nosotros
queremos escribir la ecuación del plano
para este ejemplo pues necesitamos
simplemente poner el de x de verdad
igual a que es una constante que vamos a
determinar en unos momentos que
multiplica a x menos la coordenada x 0
que es 1
uno muy bien más ve que todavía falta
determinarlo por lo menos la coordenada
de cero que en este caso es menos dos
menos -2 verdad más
efe de x 0 0 muy bien entonces vamos a
evaluar esto si nosotros evaluamos la
función en uno como menos dos tendríamos
tres menos un tercio por uno al cuadrado
por uno al cuadrado menos menos dos al
cuadrado muy bien entonces esto sería
igual a tres menos un tercio menos
cuatro entonces tres menos cuatro nos da
menos uno y menos uno menos un tercio
son menos cuatro tercios así que aquí al
final podríamos poner menos cuatro
tercios y llevamos digamos a separar
esto ahora la idea del plano tangente es
que estas constantes a ive verdad que en
esencia son las derivadas parciales de l
tengan que coincidir con las derivadas
parciales d
la función original verdad así que si
regresamos a la gráfica y pensamos en la
información de las derivadas parciales
verdad si buscamos por ejemplo la
derivada parcial de f con respecto de x
e imaginamos que nos estamos moviendo en
la dirección x justamente entonces
tenemos una rebanada que intersecta a la
gráfica en una curva y la derivada
parcial de la función f con respecto de
x nos dice la pendiente de la línea en
ese punto y queremos además que el plano
tangente tenga la misma pendiente cuando
esté por ahí verdad entonces podríamos
es simplemente escribir verdad vamos a
poner esto un poquito más abajo
podríamos escribir que queremos que sea
la derivada parcial de nuestra función f
con respecto de x pero evaluada en el
punto que nos interesa que en este caso
es 1,221 coma menos 2 y de forma análoga
podríamos calcular nuestra constante ve
muy bien en realidad podríamos pensar
que ahora inter secamos con
este plano en la dirección digamos y
aquí la pendiente es mucho más
pronunciada que en el caso anterior
verdad y al ver el plano tangente verdad
esto intersec aa la rebanada que
habíamos construido en una recta con la
misma pendiente verdad entonces vamos a
poner que b sea esa misma pendiente de
la que de la que hablábamos que es la
derivada parcial de f con respecto de g
y por supuesto esto evaluado en 1,22 uno
coma menos dos entonces vamos a dejar un
poco más de espacio solo que vamos a
copiar esta función vamos a copiarla
justamente hasta abajo muy bien entonces
vamos a hacernos más espacio y la
pondremos por aquí muy bien entonces
vamos a continuar con todo esto y ahora
vamos a calcularlo exactamente muy bien
entonces la derivada parcial de nuestra
función f con respecto de x evaluada
bueno luego le evaluamos mejor
simplemente derivamos aquí verdad si nos
damos cuenta lo que depende de x sólo
está aquí entonces tendríamos que
derivar esto y sería menos dos tercios
de equis pero ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es evaluar en x igual a 1 cierto
entonces si evaluamos en x igual a 1
esto no esto nos da menos dos tercios y
de forma similar qué pasa si calculamos
la derivada parcial de f con respecto de
y pues aquí vemos que esto es lo único
que depende de ella es menos ye cuadrada
y al derivar lo nos da menos 2 muy bien
entonces por supuesto a la hora de
evaluar en e igual a menos 2 tendríamos
menos
que multiplica a menos 2 que multiplica
a menos 2 y entonces menos 2 x menos 2
simplemente nos da 4 verdad entonces si
queremos escribir la fórmula de la de la
función cuya gráfica sea el plano
tangente tendríamos que sustituir a x
menos dos tercios y tendríamos que
sustituir a b por 4 muy bien entonces de
esta forma tendríamos aquí la fórmula de
la función cuya gráfica es el plano
tangente a la gráfica de verdad que
teníamos originalmente en el punto que
nos interesaba y esto en principio se ve
como como si fuera demasiada información
verdad necesitamos el punto uno coma
menos dos verdad tendríamos también que
calcular cuánto vale la función en ese
punto que es menos cuatro tercios y
después necesitamos ambas derivadas
parciales evaluadas en ese punto pero a
pesar de todo no no hay tantas cosas que
tengamos que recordar para calcular esto
viendo la gráfica esto tiene bastante
sentido porque el punto 12 es en
realidad el punto en donde queremos
evaluar todo verdad y al evaluar este
punto bajo la función nos indica la
tercera coordenada que esencialmente nos
colocará sobre la gráfica verdad y luego
para obtener el plano tangente
necesitamos especificar la información
de las derivadas parciales y eso nos
dice cómo tiene que orientarse la
gráfica y una vez que comienzas a pensar
geométricamente aunque de verdad
necesites esos cinco números al menos se
siente como que no podrías aparte de
ellos verdad más o menos uno tiene idea
de qué es lo que tienes que conseguir
verdad necesitamos esos números porque
de otra forma no podríamos especificar
al plano tangente bueno
dicho esto pues nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo